Let us simulate the situation in our IE.
Let us assume the individual subpatches all identified by numbers from 1 to 8.
Again, we write a testing function that simulates the behavior of the system.
We assume that if the patches 3 and 6 are applied, then the failure occurs.
If patches 3 and 6 are not applied together, then the failure does not occur.
Thanks to the beauty of Python, all of our infrastructures
we had previously set up for string also works for lists.
Let's see what happens if we test the entire set of patches.
We see it fails, which is not much of a surprise because 3 and 6 are both in here.
If we test the empty list instead, that is no patches applied, then the test passes.
Again, we print out the list we're testing, its length and the result.
Now, we can again invoke delta debugging with the set of patches and the above test function.
Let's see how this works. We invoke ddmin to see whether we can simplify this list of patches
to see which of these patches are relevant.
Press on run, here we get the result, and the final result is patches 3 and 6 suffice to cause the failure.
Well, that's something we knew all along, didn't we?
If your original patch would have been 10,000s of lines long,
then chances are that delta debugging reduces this to just two lines
or another very small set of locations in your code for which you didn't know.
But if you change these two lines, the failure will occur
and if you don't change them, the failure will not occur.
This approach for determining the culprit for regression has also been named
the blame-o-meter, as a means to know who to blame.
Where who to blame means which places in the code are to blame
but it can also mean which patches are to blame and it can also mean
which programmers made these changes which are now to blame.
The idea is that such a scheme can be used in any situation
in which an old version work and a new version does not.
So when you have any regression test failing and the regression test does exactly that
comparing the results of the new version against the old version,
you can and possibly should run delta debugging in order to figure out
which lines in the code are actually responsible for the failure.